If you were to
Zoom in phase-out,
move in focus on this
Human whose cells magnify
as you fly through them, and see
Atoms, looming
but you keep shooting past
protons, bosons, quarks til even a
part of a particles too big Then
BOOM an end to the intrusion
As you hit the resolution of the
universe the strands of its fabric
the tiniest fragment the planck length,
past that, Gravity becomes
fallacy, try contrasting that with the
galaxies try to grasp the huge magnitude
of the universe it's unimaginable.
But let's try anyway.
If that
insane length was one dollar bill
Then to reach the
wavelength of the smallest particles
Quarks, that are so fundamental
they don't have an inherent size
would be the current price you'd gain if you
sold
Mount Everest made out of gold.
That is insane.
if you applied the Midas touch to my mind
it'd be quite enough to buy a car to drive
And the gluons and 3 quarks combined
make a large hadron those guys collide;
a proton and to magnify to that
size would turn that Midas mountain
into a diamond my
mind made of that could buy you an island
and next we ramp up, from
quarks and protons to atoms,
atoms the fractions of matter the ones that
that grant us our mass, and
if that quark was counted every time you take
a
single breath you'd respire
Midas mountains then
until your death
and if that life was compressed
into one lock of hair then as we
climb / up the rest of these
atomic stairs then we'd pass
DNA when we get to my red streak
and the size of our cells
we equate to every
hair on my head...
Sometimes you make me feel so small
Can't comprehend your size
Yet I'm a giant in your eyes
If we took my
head of hair that a cell represents
lifetimes of Midas Everest breaths
and then you would stretch it out to the skyline,
again and again
you'd find circle round the earth 10 times
before you meet me... and you.
Right here the reach of a human,
a meter or two and if we were to choose
one song to represent those
horizons, an MP3 on our
device then to reach the size of the earth
compared to like our size
that's a terabyte hard drive filled with our
files
it seems immense
And if we compress that collection to one
word
to represent our world, then scaling coefficients
from the planet to the solar system
would let me re-read the whole of deathly
hallows
awesome.
And then to travel between stars
as we take to the skies
Would be 10 times every word
you'll ever say in your life
And as an analogy of the expanse of
galaxies up in space
10 times the total of every word
in every book ever made
And to move up to the scale of galaxy clusters
would be every word said by everyone in Shanghai,
in London Berlin, Delhi, LA, Mumbai, Sao Paulo
and Moscow
Jakarta, Karachi, Dubai, Telford, Tokyo and
Stockholm
And then to galaxy superclusters in the large-scale
structure
with filaments that feel inadequately described
as humungous
since if we stay with the scale of Earth as
a word that equates
to all the words everyone alive today will
ever say
finally we reach the biggest physical thing
we can confirm
The indescribable size of the observable universe
which would be more than every word that every
person ever has said
Every word that was ever written and every
word that was ever read
Sometimes you make me feel so small
Can't comprehend your size
Yet I'm a giant in your eyes.
I can't control the scope
But I'm not losing hope
To summarise
Every word that every person has ever said
in their lives
where each word implies enough MP3s to fill
a terabyte hard drive
Where each song is 10 times the number drives
to the horizon
that it'd take to ride around the world each
time you set eyes on one
where each horizon is a head of hairs
and every hair there is the length of a lifetime
and each breath in that life is the price
of mount everest made entirely by midas
and that finally describes it, and it's increasing
in size
So each time you listen to this song again
it'll be even more difficult to comprehend.